in the first two parts of this series we
explored the history of Syrian
immigrations of the United States and my
own parents immigration story in this
part we'll talk to members of the latest
wave of Syrian immigrants to the US
refugees then adjusted on your community
for get all of them and I saw animal
abuse user I can look like a Ani
you can cry factual normal men keep
ahead Anna Romano and Palermo - an
ocular man Weber composite Roy muscle by
Xena Bob doe is 20 years old and living
in America for the first time she's one
of more than 12,000 Syrian refugees who
were resettled in the u.s. in 2016
zeyneb and her family now live in my
home state of Massachusetts about an
hour from where I grew up as my parents
immigrated from Syria in the 80s her
story hit really close to home the war
in Syria has produced millions of
refugees when President Donald Trump
stood out to ban Syrian refugees with an
executive order I felt it was important
to understand what Syrian refugees
endure before coming here and the
difficulties of starting over this is a
'nope story
[Music]
my name is Benna adult from syria i want
to be able
zeinab is the oldest of five children
and the only one in her family was the
job she works part-time on the overnight
shift at Walmart and takes two different
English courses we met Zainab's family
in the middle of a February blizzard
they were still getting used to the long
Massachusetts winters that I was still
familiar with as we sat in their living
room exchanging stories and sharing food
Raynham said she never thought she
traveled far she told me the story of
their escape and our mother tongue
Arabic as well as can affect me in the
Halloween
Kim screen deity speed and I was come as
usual whoo howling Becca Kennedy moo moo
oholiab économique sukira tada
yummy Oh Taran vehicle as a quarter to
three more days to Canada attempted la
who in the hell of a foul mood so let's
welcome the fabulous thousand 2012
Venice family was especially in danger
because they were Kurdish luckily they
survived the first attack but there were
many others when I'm naked Adam
Barlowe's Arabic Allah o Allah - my lord
so far ooh my name is Bob kick me do
hair
well uh focus assist in Ravena Hannah
for master bananas se va me the Lord
with Columbus ah for Best Global drifted
back new man magic she Madonna
kunal cannulas God with cake Aniki
Saturday hope
mala Jarrett Manassas and upon my
octagon NS no Cannella no railroad 15s
Kenneth Ganga Guevara marks witnesses
ooh Xena been her family fled Aleppo to
a distant village to maintain a sense of
normalcy and concentrate on something
other than war she clung to her studies
she and her father risked their lives to
travel from the village back into Aleppo
to take her
fans at a time of severe uncertainty
education was vain of the lifeline
Oklahoma soccer class chicken wing look
at you my you know what a can Murphy can
Murphy terrible cannot be Nash more
audible Calumet it was hard for me to
wrap my mind around how dedicated they
have been her father worked education
while they dodged bombs and fire fights
patty tostada a fuckin fuckin kekkaishi
Colorado is described abandon this have
deduced as becometh Alma Monte and Oleg
equal the caffeine Oh Marsha ha ha ba ba
K no a tamale in the human knowledge
well Baba can see madam in the mocha hey
hermano de Lena sateen blood of Samuel T
back away bhutanam them now
Xena better father sacrifices paid off
when she passed her final high school
exam due to the fighting however she
couldn't register for college courses in
Aleppo and so they decided to leave
Mexico correctness auditory canal ha
Pecha Kucha ha ha ha he knows the river
Safa a handy QT cambodia cher Madonna
Venusian to do miss Montana the other
can can a man plan marilyn habian after
a harrowing journey the family crossed
the border into Turkey where the
children all work to support the family
education was a luxury they simply
couldn't afford it took about two years
worth of interviews security checks
medical tests and finally a cultural
course before the US government approved
the abdu family for resettlement
zeyneb and her family didn't know what
to expect in America or what life in
Massachusetts could offer and collect
nothing perfect he can pass of Darwin
and began in - me on sodium would be
ultimately they decided to leave it all
behind and starting over takes courage
I knew he'd kiss me yeah a kid mafia had
Ellen SPN and on to slam on a vehicle
they want anything only it would be let
let them do this see I realized that
Dana's education was crucial to a
family's survival in America whereas her
dad provided from the family as a
carpenter back in Syria he's been
struggling to find work here as he
learns English so the family is managing
on Justin as minimum wage earnings and
government and he's a who did the
Englishman and advocate already know a
lot not a Baku Nadi you can have lesbian
open geoserver and Madonna metaphor
Daniel Lumis any for Jerry Lee thought
any identification of a fluid media
manager
despite a tall table those financial
struggles haven't impacted their
hospitality and they're in good spirits
when they found out it was my birthday
they bought me a cake and three mister
prize party
[Music]
I was speechless and all those in of
life has been forever changed by war she
will let it define her I might know my
shoes I hate husband I'm dead man mr.
look deal with the schema Nathan she's
just oh I forget the other law cases why
we hired him a fish inside now can I I
was basically crying on the inside in
that last team their generosity was
unreal check out the rest of our series
on Syrian immigration to the United
States going all the way back to the
eighteen seventies